he probably had other things on his mind
but as he was driven through Westminster
the king couldn't have missed the huge
Security operation already underway
months of planning thousands of police
officers and new laws that will let them
clamp down on disruptive protests
they intend to make full use of them in
terms of disruption we've got an
extremely low threshold for anything
that will disrupt the combination that's
absolutely clear what you will probably
see or you've definitely see not
probably absolutely see is my colleagues
intervening fairly quickly we welcome
the new laws the night before a man was
arrested at Buckingham Palace suspected
of tossing shotgun cartridges over the
gates and carrying a knife police later
blew up his rucksack
Auntie monarchist Simon Hill was
arrested but not charged last year for
heckling King Charles the new laws won't
stop him protesting whatever your view
of monarchy whatever your view on every
other issue if you live in the UK you
have a right to protest because our
ancestors campaigned for that right we
all have the right to free expression
the right to protest and this is a
threat to your rights to my rights to
the rights of everybody uh listening now
whatever their views on monarching it's
something that I think she should worry
us all
police say they're not aware of any
specific threat to the coronation but a
global live television event would offer
any demonstrator a platform for
publicity the Security operation will
include facial recognition cameras
controversial technology that's opposed
by Liberty groups police say they'll use
it only to identify anybody who might
pose a threat
do you want to join the protests against
the coronation they may not have to
search far for Patrick farewell
convicted last year for throwing eggs at
the king
he's urged protesters to join him on the
day but not to bring any eggs the
Security operation will grow as
Coronation Day approaches
for now though it was business as usual
as the king hosted a Buckingham Palace
Garden Party his first as monarch
Martin brunt Sky News